let's go next to our caller from the 484
area code who's calling today from 484
oh yeah that's you oh hey David I'm
Steven I'm calling from Pennsylvania
hey Steven if you can speak up or get
closer to your phone that would be great
how about now yes that's much better so
my concern is that well Trump was um he
has some sort of interview or press
conference talking about Afghanistan and
he was bragging that he can wipe out
Afghanistan out of you know out of the
face of the earth within ten days yeah
my concern is he did is so casually he
has more information about or you know
not only know you know our opponents in
the Middle East but also there are plans
for rush and other you know countries
around the world well this is how we can
you know defeat China for example within
two weeks something like that so my
concern is if he's out of office was
like work what do you think the chances
are that he can casually say oh yeah I
remember while I was president we can
you know we were able we could take
pretty much any country within a couple
weeks yeah I mean I don't know what you
mean by if he's out of office and he
says that I so for people but the
comments are outrageous for people who
don't know Donald Trump said that if he
wanted he could have Afghanistan wiped
off the face of the earth but that he
didn't want to kill 10 million people in
doing it which is an absolutely insane
thing to say it is it strikes me as sort
of flippantly indifferent to the
possible mass murder of millions and
millions of people and you're completely
right that the casual nature with which
he said it for me reminded me of I
thought we were told that it was Hillary
who was a risk for getting us into Wars
and bloodthirsty and all of that stuff
whereas we know Trump has
considered war with who knows how many
countries at this point and his casually
mentioned if you wanted Afghanistan to
disappear as a country he could do it so
my concern is not about when he's out of
office what he'll say my concern is
right now right however for example he
has information about top secret you
know officials in different areas around
the world in those where spies are
located um determined currently last
year he shared a photo of field SEAL
Team six or something yeah and people
are saying hey you shouldn't be doing
that you just literally blew their
location and they were like you know
elite you know soldiers you know doing
having certain operations you know yes
he did do the extra missions he did do
that yeah so so he did as far as I know
this is his second time revealing what
is pretty much top-secret plans I don't
think it stops you know I don't agree
with you there I don't think Trump
revealed they needs he didn't say we
have the plan of wiping Afghanistan off
and I think anyone who just knows how
many nukes we have knows that from like
a logistical perspective we could blow
up the entire country that's true so I
don't agree with you that Trump revealed
anything classified by alluding to his a
blood lust when it comes to to
Afghanistan but I just think it was
extremely concerning thing for him to
say particularly how he said it right
but again if he was if you were somehow
logistics for nuclear weapons for
example doubt is literally something
that can take less than half an hour to
do and right because because you know
you know nuclear weapon testing not to
mention there are right now there are
nuclear submarines in the area around
the Middle East in the Pacific Ocean
Atlantic Ocean you know so um based on
the research I've done it takes about 15
minutes of flight like how far like if
it was to be launched from the US they
will take about 15 minutes just to get
to Moscow for example okay I don't know
those numbers and I'm not sure where
you're going with it but but the
comments were very very concerning and I
I appreciate the call Stephen I'm gonna
move on I'm not sure where
we're going with that last piece but I'm
glad you're paying attention to what
Donald Trump is saying let me take a
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up because I will go right back to you
just after this brief break